viele entscheidungen gestern sprechen
wir darüber mit professor gernot marx
präsident der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin also dem
chef der deutschen intensivmediziner
schönen guten tag herr max
grüße sie herr mag sind sie zufrieden
mit den beschlüssen von gestern
ja und nein es ist gut dass sich die
politik geeinigt hat und es sind sehr
viele maßnahmen jetzt vorgeschlagen oder
bundestag beschlossen worden die
sicherlich sehr gut sind wir als
intensivmediziner sehen allerdings dass
sie eine nach wie vor eine epidemische
lage von nationaler tragweite haben die
situation ist wirklich in einigen
regionen geradezu dramatisch jetzt schon
bei anderen anderen regionen angespannt
und wir haben einfach eine solche lage
und von daher verstehen wir auch nicht
warum man sich instrumente jetzt
verbietet die sich in der vergangenheit
als sehr wirkungsvoll erwiesen haben
aber er mag sind ja fast alle
instrumente weiterhin im baukasten
vorhanden außer der maximale lockdown
also die schließung zb von betrieben
oder von schulen fordern sie dass
weiterhin als möglichkeit
ich denke dass wir das im kasten haben
sollten das wäre so ähnlich als hätten
wir ein besonders wirkungsvolles
medikament mit schweren nebenwirkungen
was mir nur zur not einsetzen soll aber
wenn es dann notwendig ist hätte ich
auch gerne und so ähnlich sehe ich das
auch mit den maßnahmen die jetzt in uns
nicht mehr zur verfügung stehen er mag
es nur dass ich sie richtig verstehe das
heißt sie würden auch im jahre 2021 auch
obwohl zwei drittel der deutschen
geimpft sind dafür plädieren dass diese
möglichkeit wie der schulen zu
schliessen kitas zu schließen
möglicherweise betriebe komplett ins
home office zu schicken da wo es möglich
ist dass auch das eine möglichkeit
verbleibt
ich was ich sehe es im moment dass wir
zum beispiel in bayern unter neun
prozent freie intensivbetten haben dass
hier eine unkontrollierte ein
unkontrolliertes infektionsgeschehen
momentan mit 50 gestern 60.000
neuinfektionen von denen sie 0,8 bis 1
prozent entziehen zwölf tagen auf
unseren intensivstation wo die situation
in fast allen bundesländern so um die 10
red nur noch ist und ich glaube wir
müssen wir dürfen moment nichts
ausschließen
man darf nichts ausschließen das heißt
sie schließen auch nicht aus dass
schulschließungen noch mal kommen
könnten
wie gesagt wir müssen ich hoffe nicht
aber wir sollten wir sollten uns in der
situation wir müssen wir haben eine
situation die ist nicht kontrolliert und
wir müssen die panini bewältigen wir
müssen diese vierte welle brechen und im
moment sind wir an einem exponentiellen
wachstum gut also sie haben die
instanzen angesprochen jetzt sagen viele
experten ins agenten seien ja auch in
dieser zeit nicht mehr die entscheidende
zahl weil eben auch zwei drittel in
deutschland geimpft sind gestern hat die
politik ja nun die hospitalisierung rate
noch dazu geholt also wie viele corona
patienten pro 100000 einwohner in den
letzten sieben tagen ins krankenhaus
eingeliefert wurden ist das aus ihrer
sicht die richtige kennzahl jetzt für
die bewertung der pandemie schwere
diese zahl haben ja schon seit einer
ganzen weile und ja das ist eine
wichtige kennzahl ich glaube auch dass
die verknüpfung mit den maßnahmen eine
eine richtige entscheidung ist
allerdings ist das eben nicht nur wir
haben eben auch die belegung der
intensivbetten und das war und ist auch
eine sehr wichtige zeit war das eben
eine sehr knappe ressource ist und sie
es noch knapper im moment als vor einem
jahr wir haben aufgrund der ist fähige
mangels eben 4000 intensivbetten im
moment weniger zur verfügung als vor
einem jahr nur noch mal zur info die
zahl hatte ich mir nämlich vorher auch
ausgesucht werden in deutschland etwa
22.000 intensivbetten davon sind
3412 stand gestern von gofit patienten
belegt und es sind noch 2400 frei klingt
eigentlich nach wenig cupid patienten
aber sie sagen trotzdem das ist eine
hohe zahl
nun wir haben in bayern sachsen und
thüringen schon bereits ein drittel
aller intensivpatienten simko wird 19
patienten und die die infektion das
infektionsgeschehen nimmt ja auch an
anderen orten deutlich zu und wir sehen
eben eine lage die wir im moment nicht
im griff haben wo wir eben einen
exponentiellen anstieg der zahlen sehen
und wir sehen auch in anderen regionen
zum beispiel in aachen
oder steht region aachen relativ wenig
intensivbetten freiheit wo wir noch gar
nicht so viele kurven 19 patienten haben
es ist eben herbst und winter wir haben
auch sehr viele andere schwerkranke
patienten und insgesamt ist die lage
schon so dass wir eben eigentlich nur
noch diese 12 betten notfall kapazität
frei haben und das ist insgesamt schon
eine sehr enge lage nochmals
vitalisierung rate wir sind dabei eine
hospitalisierung rate deutschlandweit
derzeit bei 5,3 gerade mal also bei
einem drittel im vergleich zu dem wert
wo wir ende 2020 zum höhepunkt der
pandemie bahn der lag er bei
15,75 wo ist jetzt gerade die dramatik
von der sie von der angela merkel
gestern und von der lothar wieler
vorgestern der chef des robert koch
instituts gesprochen haben
nun erinnern sie sich vor einem jahr da
hatten wir etwa genau dieselben exakt
dieselben zahlen wir hatten einen lock
down leid und sie die zahlen sind
exponentiell weiter angestiegen und es
mussten daneben dann vier wochen später
entsprechend härtere maßnahmen
durchgeführt werden und wir wissen ja
was exponentielles wachstum bedeutet
dass verdoppelt sich eben jeden tag und
genau das sehen wir gerade und von daher
ist es nicht schwer auszurechnen wo wir
in den nächsten wochen hinkommen werden
wenn es uns nicht gelingt das
infektionsgeschehen unter kontrolle zu
bringen letzte frage herr professor marc
ulrich weigeldt der chef des deutschen
hausärzteverbandes der warnt vor
panikmache durch katastrophen szenarien
der chef der kassenärztlichen
vereinigung andreas gassen sagt die
situation sehr schwierig aber für panik
bestehe kein anlass ist bestehe derzeit
nicht die gefahr ich zitiere das dass
die kliniken in ihrer gesamtheit an ihre
leistungsgrenze stoßen haben ihre beiden
kollegen keine ahnung
natürlich die haben sehr viel ahnung ist
auch völlig richtig ist kein grund zur
panikmache wir müssen uns klar machen
wenn dies wenn diese und wenn dieses
infektionsgeschehen so weitergeht das
heißt dass wir dann wie in der charité
die planbaren operationen vielen
kliniken absagen müssen dass wir
insgesamt auf einen notfall modus
umschalten und dann das das sehr hohe
niveau unserer allgemeinen
gesundheitsversorgung dann nicht in der
gewohnten weise zur verfügung stehen
weil wir auch ganz viel personal dann
aus anderen bereichen in die intensiv
medizin transferieren müssen um eben
mehr betten aufzumachen und das wollen
wir möglichst nicht professor gerd marx
präsident der deutschen
interdisziplinären vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin und selbst
auch direktor der uniklinik der rwth
aachen vielen dank ihnen herr max
ich danke ihnen